today's video is brought to you by
athletic greens and its wonderful daily
blend of vitamins and minerals ag1
biathletic greens is a comprehensive
all-in-one green powder engineered to
fill the nutritional gaps in your diet
and support your body's nutritional
needs across the floor pillars of Health
gut health immune support energy and
Recovery it is packed with 75 vitamins
and minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients combining the perfect amount
of micronutrients absorption and taste
to jump start your day you'd be
hard-pressed to find a more
comprehensive powder or supplement on
the market right now now look you guys
know I'm not exactly a fitness YouTuber
but I still do have to eat right try and
take care of myself and AG one is that
comprehensive nutritional supplement
that I know is going to account for any
holes that I might have in my diet and
let's be honest they are many
pop a scoop of this stuff from the jar
in here every morning I have it usually
with a cup of coffee and I just feel it
has me covered for the day plus age one
is gluten-free dairy free paleo vegan
keto low allergen and low calorie it's
less than one gram of sugar per serving
now one of the things I personally like
is I feel like it gives me a bit of a
boost of energy in the morning along
with that coffee probably means I'm
drinking less coffee which is nice look
it's perfect dietary support regimen so
if this sounds like the supplement
you've been looking for grab your own
immunity bundle which includes a year
supply of vitamin D and five travel
packs for free at athleticreens.com
biographic again your supply vitamin D
the travel packs at athleticreens.com
biographics or just click the link in
the description below and now today's
video
foreign
the 20th century was marked by the rise
of regimes founded upon the most
catastrophic ideologies ever to plague
Humanity these political extremes have
been often identified with the ideals
and deeds of a single hateful actor a
Man of Steel in Moscow a Helmsman in
Beijing or simply a leader in Berlin but
these characters did not develop in a
vacuum they were funded inspired and
coached by other secondary Players whose
names are too often overlooked in
today's biographics we're going to learn
about an author whose writings boast the
dubious honor of having inspired the
Century's most hateful racial theories a
poet and journalist whose ideas and
Endeavors helped shape the early setup
of a certain Fringe party a playwright
who coached the leader of that faction
and supported his rise to power this is
the story of Dietrich Eckhart the man
who mentored Adolf Hitler
oh when talking about the higher
echelons of the Third Reich leadership
that names that usually spring to mind a
Hermann Goering Heinrich Himmler Joseph
Goebbels or chief ideologue Alfred
Rosenberg so who was this Eckhart guy
Dietrich Eckhardt died in December 1923
10 years before the Nazis took power but
his association with the early leaders
of the party was so influential that
Hitler dedicated part of Mein Kampf to
him and an SS contingent wore an armband
bearing eckhart's name as a badge of
honor the fuhrer described Eckhart as
someone who dedicated his life in
versing thinking and eventually in
acting towards the Awakening of his
people the dictator often referred to
Eckhart as his ideological father a
source of inspiration as well as a
mentor what really resonated with the
early Nazi movement however was
eckhart's rabid pathological form of
anti-Semitism rooted in an apocalyptic
worldview Eckhart did not maintain that
a Jewish conspiracy was out to Rule the
World Behind the Scenes no he believed
that Jews were out to destroy the world
bringing about a final battle Armageddon
but let's take it from the start shall
we
Dietrich Eckhart was born in neumark
Bavaria Germany on March the 23 1868. he
was the son of Christian Doral notary
and his second wife Anna Christie was
quite the big shot in no I marked a man
who seldom was contradicted he expected
the same level of respect at home and
frequently clashed with the young
insubordinate Dietrich on the other hand
Anna was delicate and gentle protecting
Dietrich from Christian's disciplinary
and outbursts friends of Dietrich
Eckhart would later remark how he had
inherited character traits from both
parents alternating moments of poetic
tenderness with fits of Rage when
Dietrich was only 10 Anna died without
his mother's mediation the young Eckhart
butted heads frequently with his father
and other forms of authority Dietrich
was expelled from several schools so
Christian decided to ship him to
boarding schools all around Bavaria
Dietrich was not a remarkable student
but he succeeded in applying to study
medicine at the University of erlangan
here Dietrich showed little interest in
academics preferring to spend time with
the cause on oldia a Student Association
akin to her fraternity the boy son
devoted himself to the core's main
activities dueling and drinking during
the frequent festivals organized by the
fraternity Eckhart was invited to open
Libations with readings of his own
verses he had become their official Bard
unsurprisingly Dietrich did not make any
progress in his studies which he then
abandoned in the Academic Year
1890-1891. Dietrich had fallen ill from
an unspecified disease which required
morphine as a treatment he eventually
developed a Strong Addiction which led
him to consume near overdose quantities
this dependence on opioids led him to
abandoning University and checking into
a sanatorium for nervous diseases he
later characterized this period as a
critical phase of his development
Eckhart started experimenting with
playwriting and he even staged some of
his Productions using other patients as
actors upon discharge in 1893 Dietrich
decided to opt for another form of
literary expression he was going to
become a poet
[Music]
in 1893 Dietrich succeeded in publishing
two short volumes of verse the first was
a collection of poems by Heinrich Hein
selected and edited by Eckhart
heinrichheim born in 1797 died in 1856
is a giant of German literature and a
post-traumatic poetry in particular the
Hein was born in a Jewish family but
facing widespread discrimination in
Prussia he had converted to
protestantism when writing about Hein
Eckhardt portrayed him as a towering
figure a patriot who championed German
unification and morally and
intellectually Advanced Soul who battled
against the narrow-mindedness of a
reactionary Society quite surprising for
a future anti-semite Eckhart Associated
Heinz positive traits to him being
originally Jewish the second volume
published by Dietrich was a collection
of his own poetry in his poems Dietrich
established the theme of his
disappearing youth as a lost Homeland in
the long poem The Flower and the River
Jordan the author identifies himself
with the Jews he like them feels cast
out of his homeland the piece then
describes the author's love of a
beautiful Jewish girl he follows her to
a synagogue to observe her and the girl
mistakes him for being a Pious Jew and
she smiles at him he also amuses that he
wished he was Jewish too if it meant
sharing a kiss with the young lady now
we're not literary critics but allow us
to say that his choice of words portray
a little bit of prejudice oh I would
really want to be or what she believed a
patent Jew boy was naturally curly hair
the crooked nose I would have accepted
it for a kiss on those lips and a sweet
word of Love Eckhart moved swiftly to
another Endeavor journalism to fund his
old morphine habit and a new addiction
to alcohol in 1894 he became a regular
contributor to the samler a literary
supplements for which he wrote satiric
reportages mocking the German middle
classes in the summer of the same year
he was assigned to cover the annual
buyer at a festival dedicated to Richard
Wagner's music and operas these articles
prompted Eckhart to reflect on the
contrast between the values of an
idealized medieval Germany as portrayed
in Wagner's works and the moral vacuum
of the Contemporary second Reich marked
by the greed of social climbers these
ideas are a voiced in eckhart's next
volume published at the end of 1895.
this was tanhoiser on vacation this
character a 13th century poet was also
the protagonist of a wagnerian Opera
Eckhart imagines him as he reawakens in
the 19th century in Germany providing
social commentary in verse in one
episode tanheiser visits the parliament
in Berlin describing it as a meaningless
institution run by privileged fools
disconnected from the common folk it
appears also that Eckhart was moving
away from his initial sympathy towards
Judaism as his protagonist notes that
Jews stand apart with their Superior
cleverness and ambition which makes them
dangerous to German Society tanoisa
concludes we must always brandish the
hammer if we don't want to become the
Anvil
foreign
in the same year 1895 eckhart's father
Christian died leaving Eckhart with the
sizable inheritance Dietrich however
squandered all of it on his habits and
an expensive lifestyle Eckhart would
consume 20 sausages and six pints of
beer in a typical evening the next
morning he would drink gallons of coffee
brewed with expensive beans and
throughout the day he puffed on at least
15 expensive cigars and of course he
would treat his friends and occasional
lovers to the same Lifestyle
unsurprisingly by 1897 his pockets were
almost empty and his health was in a
terrible State Eckhart recovered for one
year in Leipzig before moving to Berlin
in the Autumn of 1899. initially he was
so broke that he had to sleep on park
benches but a series of gigs with local
Berliner papers got him back onto his
feet encouraged by friends and
co-workers Eckhart expanded his literary
Arsenal by writing plays and short
stories usually historical in tone his
targets included the middle classes the
breakdown of German moral values and of
course the Jews more precisely the
monolithic Jewish Clique which alleged
controlled most German newspapers as
well as the theater scene in Berlin a
clique which according to Eckhart
prevented his plays from enjoying the
success that they deserved by 1905 it
appears that eckhart's worldview had
rapidly degenerated into conspiracy
theory German Society culture and
economy has enjoyed great advancement
since unification in 1871 and yet in his
view this progress had devastated
traditional German values and brought
forward the specters of socialism
unbridled capitalism and cultural
pluralism and the force behind this
change was of course a cabal of Jewish
financiers and Moguls his anti-Semitism
had become so rabid that he repudiated
his once hero Heinrich heiner these
ideas serve as an eckhart's only
moderately successful play to that date
The Family Man the protagonist is a
journalist and a playwright who
antagonizes the heartless heinzer the
Jewish owner of a daily newspaper his
next play The Frog King bombed
completely Eckhart blamed the failure on
Jewish critics and fell into a
depression retreating to his hometown of
deusmarkt in 1906. between 1906 and 1910
Eckhart went through a rough patch work
was scarce and he scored only occasional
paydays by writing ad copy for
pharmaceutical companies but in general
his bag balance and his mood were so low
that he had to go through psychiatric
treatment again things picked up again
in the Autumn of 1911 when Eckhart
finished working on a translation of
peer gint by Norwegian playwright Henrik
Ibsen the plot sees the protagonist a
poet with a drinking habit battle trolls
and the boyg a sort of shapeless blob
after escaping from these creatures peer
becomes a slave trader in Morocco winds
up in a psychiatric asylum in Cairo and
eventually returns to Norway to die
Eckhart strongly identified with the
main character whom he saw as a
pure-hearted defender of Traditional
Values who fought against the shapeless
blob of modern society and the cunning
trolls who he considered to be stand-ins
for the Jews eckhardt's version of the
play had such strong anti-semitic
overtones that Henry ibsen's son refused
permission to Stage it but Eckhart had a
powerful friend in George vonchus and
Heisler the superintendent of the raw
theater Paulson himself was close to
German Kaiser Wilhelm II according to a
colleague of Eckhart Albert Reich the
Kaiser himself pulled some strings to
staged the play Dietrich eckhart's peer
gint premiered in February 1914 becoming
his only truly big success Berlin's
Royal Theater ran 183 consecutive
performances to packed houses before the
production went on a European tour
Eckhart was suddenly flush with cash
from royalties and was able to pay off
his 11 000 marks worth of debt
foreign
on the 1st of August 1914 Germany
declared war on Russia the Great War was
on Eckhart was too old to join the
military but he would serve his country
in another way in 1913 kilson had given
him a commission to write a patriotic
play about Holy Roman Emperor Henry VI
Eckhart checked into a sanatorium to
better concentrate and dove into the
assignment when the war started he
cranked up the Patriotic and
anti-english overtones the piece
premiered in January 1915 and apparently
the anti-english propaganda was so
heavy-handed that the German government
actually had it censored Eckhart was not
amused but he did have a shoulder to cry
on while it was sanatorium he courted
Mrs Rose Marx a widow with three
daughters the two married on September
15 1913 and after a honeymoon in Munich
they decided to move there permanently
while there in 1916 Dietrich and Rose
became friends with Michael Conrad a
magazine editor who sympathized with
eckhart's nationalistic worldviews in
January 1917 Conrad published an article
about Eckhart portraying him as a
Teutonic Giant and a leading patriotic
writer Conrad's article opened the
floodgates with several Publications
requesting eckhart's pieces attacking
the enemies of Germany both outside and
inside its borders it was in this period
that Eckhart anti-Semitism first took on
individual targets targets such as Leon
Trotsky an embodiment of how Jewish
interest manipulated and infiltrated
bolshevism journalism work did not
attract Eckhart from writing another
play set in 1537 Florence this was
Lawrence Hatchell completed in October
1918. the titular character feuds
against the Medici family portrayed as
scheming half-jewish Bankers the
protagonist is eventually killed but he
enjoys a [ __ ] and act wandering which
his supporters chant Our Redeemer our
Fiora no one purera one month later on
November 11 1918 Germany had to concede
defeat to the ontant the Great War was
over then the second German Reich was
crumbling Eckhart firmly believed that
Germany's defeat was the result of a
stab in the back perpetrated by
communist social Democrats financiers
and the Jews
again he decided to start a paper that
would denounce the decadence of the new
government the Weimar Republic and he
would do so in plain German or Alfred
Deutsch
Alpha Deutsch was in fact the name
chosen for this new Endeavor to kick it
off Eckhart needed money and so he
approached a cultist and newspaper
editor Rudolph on C botendorf
seabotendorf was the founder of the Tula
Society an anti-semitic anti-communist
group with an interest in German history
folklore and occultism it would be
joined by Future Nazi leaders such as
Rudolf Hess and Alfred Rosenberg
seabotendorff had invited Earhart to
lecture at the Tulare Society on
previous occasions but had no wish to
fund a competitor to his own paper the
Munich Observer eventually eckhart's
occurred ten thousand marks from another
editor and immediately set to work by
1920 ufgood Deutsch's circulation peaked
at 30 000 copies eckhart's
anti-communist and anti-semitic stance
attracted contributors from the likes of
Alfred Rosenberg an economist Godfrey
and Federer the trio warned that readers
about the impending danger of a Russian
Jewish Revolution as an alternative to
bolshevism they championed a fringe
party which Eckhart and Federer had
co-founded with agitator and Drexler the
d.a.p or German Workers party I do note
that the DAP would later evolve into the
nsdap I.E the Nazi party their worst
fears became true in April 1919 with the
outbreak of the Spartacus Revolt a
Bolshevik government was temporarily
installed in Munich which led Eckhart to
perform several acts of anti-communist
resistance for example on April the 6th
he and Federer drove through Munich
handing out a hundred thousand copies of
a pamphlet called to all workers which
criticized the communist government he
then collected money from rich friends
which he used to bribe Spartacus
officials into releasing too low Society
members from jail on the 16th of April a
squad of Spartacus arrested him at
gunpoint but Eckhart Charmed them with
his banter and took them home for some
drinks while drunk he pulled out his ant
communist pamphlet and by reading select
passages he convinced the Communists
that he was on their side
the Spartacus Revolution was short-lived
and soon the Weimar government regained
control with the help of far-right
militias Eckhart and his d.a.p acolytes
however continued to stir anti-communist
sentiment on September 12 1919 an army
Corporal was sent to spy on a meeting of
the d.a.p he ended up joining a heated
discussion and his rhetoric was so
effective that he was invited to join
the party his name was Adolf Hitler
initially Hitler was not impressed with
party leadership with one exception
Dietrich Eckhart the two first met in
October 1919 and they instantly clicked
they shared similar views on what had
caused Germany's defeat in the Great War
than they were both staunch nationalists
moreover they had similar upbringings
with loving mothers and disciplinarian
fathers they both said dabbled in the
Arts and had experienced failure and
poverty Eckhart took Hitler under his
wing lecturing him on his own brand of
anti-Semitism to Eckhart Judaism was a
secret power as old as history and Jews
had directed all major changes in
humanity often under false name
bolshevism was just another Jewish
strategy to divert attention from the
true goal of the conspiracy controlling
and eventually destroying the world
bolshevism in fact was much older than
people believed as a movement it could
be traced back to Moses himself as a
rebel against the Pharaohs he had been
the first Bolshevik when they were not
discussing such lofty arguments in beer
halls and turbans Eckhart acted as
Hitler's Pygmalion refining his looks
his dress code and mannerisms the former
playwright coached his younger friends
on how to address a crowd with
rabble-rousing further or when needed
how to tone down his spiteful Persona to
mingle with the upper classes Eckhart
had realized that the DAP needed support
from the highest echelons of society
Hitler's Charisma always their most
precious asset but he needed some
refinement thanks to eckhart's guidance
and introductions Hitler was able to
meet Aristocrats and industrialists many
of whom would later join support or
Finance the DAP such as Publishers Hugo
Brockman and Ernst hofstungle in
November of 1919 and Eckhart Hitler
Dragster and Federer worked together on
the program of the DAP later known as
the 25 points in January 1920 Eckhart
supported Hitler in becoming the party's
propaganda Chief and on February 24 1920
Hitler gave proof of his oratorical
abilities by delivering speeches to
audiences of 2000 his largest crowds yet
after the speech dap leadership revealed
the 25 points and officially changed
their name by including the word
nationalists and socialists the latter
being added to appeal to workers and
left-wing supporters the German national
as Socialist Workers Party or Nazi party
for short who was born in March 1920
Eckhart and Hitler tried to coordinate
their political agenda with the
right-wing coup taking place in Berlin
on March 12 a group of generals
installed Chancellor Wolfgang carp who
happened to be a friend and financial
supporter of aircards Cap's agenda
included the arrest of those Jews who
had allegedly stabbed the back of the
German Army on the 17th their cotton
Hitler hopped on a three-seater plane
and flew to Berlin to meet with cap but
as soon as they landed they learned that
the whole coup had melted away as cap
lacked support from civilian authorities
it was a debacle but God Hitler thinking
about staging a coup of his own
over the following months Eckhart
continued advising Hitler ensuring that
his star Rose Among the ranks of the
party for example he encouraged Hitler
into wooing Julius Stryker into joining
the Nazis Striker was a leading member
of the German Socialist Party as he
switched sides he brought along enough
former socialists to double membership
at the Nazi party then in December 1920
Eckhart and Hitler persuaded Anton
Draxler that their party should own a
newspaper Jackson agreed and the mentor
mentee Duo raked in the necessary funds
four hundred and seventy thousand marks
collected from party members and an army
slash fund they then proceeded to buy
Von seabotendorf's paper the Munich
Observer which they re-christened the
people's Observer or Volks Kisha
beerbachta this newspaper would remain
the Nazi's main propaganda Outlet until
the downfall of the regime some months
later Eckhart was Central to another key
event in Nazi history on July the 11th
1921 Hitler quit the party after a
dispute with Anton drexlow wanted closer
ties with socialists Drexler feared
losing his propaganda Chief and so he
asked Eckhart to intervene Eckhart
agreed and advised Hitler to return on
his own terms he would rejoin the Nazis
but only as their unquestionable leader
it's fuhrer Eckhart then supported
Hitler in his next move recruiting a
group of street fighters as part of the
party sports section this would become
the first core of the SA or the brown
shirt the paramilitary thugs headed by
Ernst ROM so Dietrich Eckhart had said
his Protege on a steep course towards
political leadership and success Hitler
did not need eckhart's hand-holding
during his next visit to Berlin in May
1922 during which he forged an alliance
with legendary Great War General Eric
ludendorff the middle-aged former
playwright was by now suffering from
poor health years of morphine Alcohol
Tobacco and overwork had taken their
toll back in March 1921 eckhart's wife
Rose had filed for divorce tired of her
husband's wild habits and in August
Dietrich moved to obisalsberg on the
Alps for a restorative holiday Banner
his new 16 year old girlfriend kept in
company from August to December 1922 he
almost completely withdrew from activism
over this period the relationship
between Eckhart and Hitler cooled off
Hitler had outgrown his teacher and did
not need his advice to thrive in fact in
January 1923 Hitler led a large Nazi
rally in Munich four days arousing
speeches followed by Massive brawls with
Communists Eckhart observed from afar
and lamented that his mentee relied too
much on violence and may have been
developing a messiah complex and yet
Hitler was still willing to step in to
protect his mentor in April of 1923
Eckhart returned to Munich when he
learned that the magistrator had issued
an arrest warrant against him but libel
and ensignment of violence from the
pages of alfgood Deutsche Eckhart went
on the lamb and Hitler intervened
putting ernstrom on the case ROM planned
Eckhart escape from Munich who fled the
city disguised as an army officer The
Fugitive hid for several weeks in the
Bavarian Alps where he was soon joined
by Hitler he needed to lay low too after
a failed attempt to raid an army weapons
Depot
foreign
after the latest Adventure Eckhart
settled into the routine of an ill
Wheezy middle-aged man prone to
self-pity and pestering friends for
money in October 1923 he learned that
the arrest warrant against him had been
rescinded and so he braved returning to
Munich to join Hitler for a series of
speeches but the chasm between the two
had opened again Eckhart warned Hitler
against planning a coup or taking power
with violent methods he believed that
the path of Victory lay in Democratic
methods Hitler on the other hand yearned
for Action Mussolini had marched on Rome
so he would march on Munich the fuhrer
now had little time for his old Mentor
he described as an old pessimist and a
it's a maniac on November 8 1923 Hitler
General ludendorff and other
conspirators staged their coup known as
the beer hall pitch Eckhart had not even
been informed and was kept out of the
action which well turned out to fail
miserably however as a party member
Eckhart was arrested on November 15th
and imprisoned in Munich after five
weeks in jail Eckhart covered a heart
attack and Bavarian authorities decided
to release him on December 21st lest
they get a martyr on their hands but
Dietrich Eckhart was living on borrowed
time on the 26th of December 1923 he
died of heart failure in Burke's Garden
Eckhart had been almost repudiated by
his friend and disciple Adolf Hitler and
he had grown dubious of the latter's
narcissistic and Psychopathic Tendencies
and yet his influence was undeniable
sure Hitler and his acolytes would have
developed extreme nationalism
anti-communism anti-Semitism as Chief
tenets of their ideology regardless but
without eckhart's backing the Obscure
Austrian Corporal may have never climbed
the ranks of the DAP party nor would he
have been given the connection and
alliances which paved his rise to power
so I really hope you found today's video
interesting if you did please do hit
that like button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]